the nine singers on this movable
platform create an unusual ensemble
known as the pendulum choir
it's the brainchild of swiss artists
Andre and machete cause de la musique
ejecta the music I wrote is about three
then sbic on docker do you think of the
choir as a long as something very
organic sorry saga Nika explore the
relationship between movement and music
empirically voy a la musica the
choreography the movement of the
machines is precisely calculated and yet
every performance is still different
there are always slight changes that
means the two brothers have to react
spontaneously for instance when the
singing of a passage take slightly
longer than planned I just focal come
with pre-programmed everything is in
Darwin jisuk wins we're there to switch
on the prepared sequences in stencil so
I to charlotte tonight but still
depending on how the choir sang today
the choir is performing in the artists
homeland in western switzerland in the
town of 7yi they're appearing as part of
leesia damn use eco an annual
contemporary music festival
more than 200 people came to see and
hear the pendulum choir and were
thrilled by the performance I really
loved it I don't know I thought it
brother mesmerizing what's up it raises
questions there's a futuristic aspect to
it i like very much I'm sure to keep
reliving the performance in my mind I'd
like to see it again so depending off of
Wow enthusiam for wonderful wonderful me
but it's not easy to take it wasn't very
cheerful about it a few hours earlier
the singers were getting strapped into
their platforms around a meter off the
ground the deco styles have worked with
the same ensembles since the pendulum
choir made its debut two years ago its
members are classically trained singers
from Switzerland France and Germany the
choir has performed internationally and
this year it's already one renowned
awards in Austria and Japan
thus the shine it looks tough and
dangerous and so forth but it's not
really so strange zoo empathy man Kenya
you can sing in any position in opera
you sometimes have to sing while sitting
or lying on your back seeing the the
breath is difficult to do breathing
normally with the belt but we have now
the make a lot of time and now it's a
second second nature just a few
kilometers away from the festival venue
is the artists workshop on the top floor
of this building under the name called
act the D Coast AM brothers have been
designing and constructing prize-winning
art installations since 1997 this one
called cycloid e transforms the swinging
of a horizontal pendulum into sounds the
interaction between movement and sound
is at the heart of this installation too
when creating the technology behind the
pendulum choir they tried to make the
movements look natural there's been just
one close call when one of the platforms
suddenly stopped moving rashon to hit
the the singer was trapped he was stuck
yeah and the other singers were in
difficult positions to then audience
members got up a deal is they untuk on
the singers and helped him get down nah
dude M&T
it was quite a spectacle good names or
it was unprecedented there were lots of
people there let's go they thought it
was great my god we were completely
Shiloh show kids I see now every singer
can bring the pendulum choir to a
standstill at the touch of a button
should something go wrong but standing
at funny angles and singing funny sounds
is part and parcel of the performance
you